bonjour je vous entends journal les
journaux gratuits une petite révolution
dans les grandes villes depuis 2002
présente bien il a erré et pourtant
l'histoire n'avait pas bien commencé
qu'en métro le premier quotidien gratuit
débarque en france le 18 février 2002 il
est dans le viseur de la presse
traditionnelle
les syndicats du livre dénonce des
salaires trop faibles et des journaux
qui échappent aux circuits de
fabrication classique dès la parution du
premier numéro les syndicats empêche la
distribution à paris et à marseille
les exemplaires sont détruits démarche
encore ce soir
elle continuera demain on continuera
tant qu'on n'aura pas ce débat public
avec des propositions concrètes sur
l'aide à la presse le développement et
la garantie d'un statut des personnels
sans compter que les gratuits sont
intégralement financée par la publicité
d'où une mise en cause de leur
indépendance la presse traditionnelle
craint malgré tout ce nouveau concurrent
tout autant qu'elle le dénigre n'y aura
pas le travail de plus values
rédactionnelle de l'éditorial des
reportages des enquêtes un peu lourde
tout ce travail qui est là engage des
frais considérables donc ce sont des
sous journaux et je soupçonne leurs
initiateurs de les faire pour un sou
public
pour autant les dirigeants des gratuits
assure ne pas vouloir rentrer dans cette
guerre nous allons chercher d'autres
lecteurs que la presse traditionnelle
mal à capter ce sont des vecteurs jeunes
et c'est sous les lecteurs qui
alors représentant marché publicitaire
extrêmement important en métro 20
minutes et les autres un million deux
cent mille exemplaires quotidiens en
2002 c'est autant que l'électorat du
monde du figaro et de l'équipe réunit la
presse traditionnelle riposte aussitôt
et lance ses propres gratuit lyon plus
lancé par le progrès marseille plus
édité par la provence et une dizaine
d'autres
cela n'empêche pas 20 minutes et métro
de se hisser peu à peu parmi les titres
les plus lus 20 minutes en tête avec en
2006 presque 2 millions de lecteurs
quotidiens devant le monde le parisien
métro et le figaro encore en 2017
20 minutes est élu par 3783603 papier et
numérique
toujours leader devant les titres de
presse payante
[Musique]